upcycling
is the latest environmentally friendly
trend
currently taking over the fashion world
what is upcycling you ask i have the
same questions
and to find out we've teamed up with our
friends at lg
who know a thing or two about
clothing care hi nicole i'm so excited
to meet you
i'm kind of star struck i'm not kidding
i
am one of your biggest fans first of all
i think if you look up the definition of
cool in the dictionary your picture is
probably there
oh my gosh what to you
is upcycling upcycling is taking
materials and things that already exist
in our world today
and creating it into something new to
maximize it and give it longevity
upcycling can be taking a garment and
totally reinventing it
and today you're going to take this
sweatshirt and make it into a bag
yes to keep it from going into landfills
we have to find creative solutions for
it
lg is creating awareness of how to care
for clothes because they're giving us
the opportunity to wash things
and take care of our clothing so it'll
create another life for them
i'm obsessed with the lg wash tower and
algae stylish steam closet in our
dressing room and i actually use the
wash tower
to clean this sweatshirt that nicole and
i will upcycle into something great for
the summer
we're gonna crop the sleeves off of it
and take the excess
and turn that into a little matching bag
[Music]
now we have our summer satchel bag it's
so cute
it like hurts i love that you chose like
that adorable
mint cream to learn more about how you
can give a second life to your clothes
and get some clothing care tips check
out lg secondlife.com
thank you
you